yesterday we did a segment about some of
the early
wacky questions that we saw at the joe
biden white house press secretary jen
sackey's
press briefings uh these questions
overwhelmingly coming from
a peter ducey a reporter at fox news
who apparently now is part of the white
house press corps and we played some of
those stories
yesterday um it is not just peter ducey
now but there are now multiple reporters
who seem
completely determined to make gensake's
white house press briefings as much of a
joke as they can
make them despite uh the dramatic
improvement the upgrade that we've seen
from kaylee mcinanni to jen sackey who
actually provides
real information of value and substance
doesn't denounce the media as an
institution when they ask tough
questions
so i have more of these we're going to
look at some peter ducey clips from
yesterday and other reporters
here's a a hypothetical from peter ducey
what if
what if the senate can't do impeachment
of trump
and something else at the same time
another question
the president says that he hopes that
the senate leadership
can continue uh can do the impeachment
trial
while working on the people's business
what if they can't
well as as president you always have to
be hopeful of course
um that's a completely absurd
hypothetical that again doesn't even
involve
biden peter ducey and other right-wing
reporters
determined to say to gen saki
and to joe biden and others shouldn't
you intervene
in the senate impeachment trial and
either say to do this or to do that or
to not do this again joe biden should
have no involvement whatsoever
in the senate impeachment trial he
shouldn't tell any senator on the
republican or democratic side
to do something or not to do something
he should simply not be involved
in any way and that is going to be uh
hopefully
the continued response from gensake and
from joe biden
peter ducey then with another question
um
shouldn't the rioters in portland also
be
seen as domestic extremists if you are
seeing the january 6th
rioters as domestic extremists or
domestic terrorists
just one more the riots in portland and
the violence in portland recently
there was some discussion earlier about
the january 6th rioters being reviewed
by the dni
as domestic violent extremists are the
rioters in portland
also being viewed through the same lens
or is that something different
that's the white house i think we you
and i talked about this yesterday and
conveyed that
uh all violence happening around the
country will be reviewed so what jenn
sackey does well is not react much and
just say
yeah sure review everything she could
say
well hold on a second peter what we had
on january 6th
was x incited by the sitting then
sitting president of the united states
what we've seen in portland is something
very
don't even get into it just tell them
we're going to look at everything and
review everything yeah sure
why not uh because that he wants to get
a reaction from her and she does a good
job there of of not giving him one
uh here he asks and and again this is
it's the same hypotheticals is joe biden
supportive
of florida hosting the olympics if japan
backs out due to coronavirus fears
there is a report now that the chief
financial officer
of florida has sent a letter to the
international olympic committee that
florida would like to host the olympics
if japan next year
is uncomfortable because of the pandemic
is a florida olympics in 2021 something
you can see the white house
supporting wow well that's a lot of
steps that need to take place and i
don't know the entire process of the
olympics but i would certainly think
send you to the u.s olympic committee
and the international olympic committee
first um on what their assessment of
that offer is and certainly of course
what their assessment is
of japan's preparedness for the olympics
this
is you know he he might as well go to my
type of question
jen does the biden administration
believe that a
taco is a type of pizza is an empanada a
latin american calzone
from the perspective of the biden
administration these are
meaningless questions and by the way on
the merits it's ridiculous but i'll get
to that in a second
if it is true that japan decides in the
future not to do the olympics
and if it is true that florida is
interested and capable of doing it
what would joe biden's give me a break
give me a break and by the way the
funniest thing about that is
japan as a country has far better
coronavirus numbers than florida and
florida's just one of 50 american states
japan as a country if japan as a country
says
based on the data we don't want to do
the olympics due to kovid
there's no way in hell that it should go
to florida florida's been a much bigger
disaster
uh okay another reporter jumps in and
asks what is donald trump what is i'm
sorry what is joe biden's position
on donald trump endorsing sarah huckabee
sanders
in the republican arkansas gubernatorial
primary
of 2022. yeah you might be wondering
what what why
why is why would joe biden take a
position on that and indeed he is not
take a look at this
yesterday former president trump
endorsed sarah huckabee sanders for
governor of arkansas in 2022
where does president biden stand on that
particular race and how high is this on
his list of priorities
well how high is the arkansas republican
gubernatorial primary on the president's
list of priorities
not high i can confirm for you i'm not
running for governor of connecticut in
the future so i'm here to confirm that
for you as well
these are just completely farcical
questions and we'll talk a little bit
later in the show about sarah huckabee
sanders gubernatorial run
here is one more back to peter ducey
asking
joe biden what did you talk to vladimir
putin about and biden handles this
perfectly and says we talked about you
peter
mr president what you're talking about
about
you
i do find it entertaining that joe biden
clearly finds peter ducey entertaining
and he seems to deliberately let him ask
questions
and what is absolutely fascinating to me
is that on the one hand
these reporters like peter ducey they
seem determined to turn the press
briefings with gen saki
and with biden himself into
opportunities to attack people with
questions now i think that that's fine
notice how different the reaction is
from gen saki and from joe biden
the trump administration would have
maybe kicked him out as they did at one
point
cnn reporter jim acosta they would have
denounced the media as an institution
they would have scolded the entire room
because they didn't like the question
from one person um i like that gen saki
and joe biden just answer the questions
with the seriousness that they deserve
on a case-by-case basis and sometimes
these questions don't really require a
very serious answer
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water
for rehydration and they're giving you
25 percent off your first
order it's made with four key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
tastes great it's made with real fruit
juice it's been a great part of my daily
routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect
way to rehydrate especially because it's
cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
percent off your first order when you go
to drinkhydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video